mes chers amis juste un mot pour qu'on
soit très franc les uns avec les autres
le travail de la commission
d'investitures qu'amener christian
estrosi toute son équipe étaient
extrêmement difficiles
je vous remercie du vote que vous avez
exprimées ça ne veut pas dire que
j'ignore qu'il ya des déceptions je les
prends en compte
il ya beaucoup de gens parmi nos qui
aurait pu être candidat
aussi bien que ceux qui ont été choisis
il a fallu faire rentrer sans personne
pour dix places mille personnes pour 10
places il a fallu faire des efforts avec
nos partenaires centristes
il a fallu faire des efforts entre les
plus anciens les plus nouveaux il a
fallu faire des efforts pour tenir
compte des équilibres géographiques
il a fallu faire des efforts pour faire
la place aux jeunes y en a pas assez
et je comprends parfaitement que dans
toute liste jean pierre il ya des
déceptions je veux pas que vous croyez
qu'on passe tout ça par pertes et
profits
la deuxième chose que je veux dire très
brièvement aux têtes de liste c'est
qu'on est fiers d'eux de leur travail de
leur courage de leur campagne ils
peuvent compter sur le parti dans son
ensemble et nous nous voulons compter
sur eux mais dans le combat qu'il faut
mener
il ya la part personnelle que chacun
d'apprendre mais c'est pas rien d'aller
au combat avec l'étiquette des
républicains et y compris si vous
regardez les sondages
les études c'est pas rien respecter
cette étiquette respecter votre famille
politique c'est bien de faire tout pour
sa formation politique avant d'avoir
investiture une fois qu'on l'a n'oubliez
pas n'oubliez pas parce que ça ne serait
pas juste
et parce que ça serait manquer de
respect et je suis sûr que tous ici
laisse pas bruno le maire pense comme
moi ça serait manquer de respect à tous
ceux qui auraient pu être candidats qui
n'ont pas été parce qu'on n'a pas choisi
nathalie et qui l'acceptent et enfin en
politique est quelque chose auquel
j'attache beaucoup de prix le respect de
la parole donnée
il croyait bien
j'essaie de m'appliquer cette règle je
compte sur les têtes de liste
je veux voir sur les listes les
candidats qui auront été investis par
notre famille politique c'est le respect
c'est la dignité c'est l'honnêteté
l'honnêteté le respect de la parole
donnée c'est comme ça qu'on crée une
famille politique
et si entre nous on respecte notre
parole les français qui nous regardent
et qui ne sont pas de notre combat qui
n'ont peut-être pas partager tous nos
combats se diront ceux là on peut leur
faire confiance parce qu'à l'intérieur
ils ont fait ils se font confiance j'ai
dû prendre des décisions difficiles je
n'y reviens pas parce que je ne suis pas
un commentateur la vie politique
quand on est chef d'une famille on doit
décider mais je veux dire que c'est pas
une auberge espagnole ici est une
discipline et une organisation et un
projet il ya des choses qui se disent il
ya des choses qui se disent pas il ya
des candidats qu'on soutient fond et
quand l'un d'entre vous êtes attaqués
on sera tous avec lui mais on veut qu à
linverse l' inverse soit la même